question from lord overlay who's your
favorite gm
uh probably beth harmon
hey okay we have a game
there was a question earlier to show
ponziani ideas
so let's play the ponziani
and let's try and find
some ideas
um actually haven't played the ponzi on
in a while
the f6 is most common
d4
oh okay so we're going into this line
this is actually one of the most
dangerous lines
that white can encounter in ponziani
um bishop b6 best move
and now queen d5
yeah knight f2
i know i'm trying to remember i think
rook g1
i have some analysis somewhere but
um
it's a very sharp position so the point
is if i takes takes takes and then takes
and
everything's a mess
i'll play rook g1
the nice thing about this line is at
least most people aren't prepared super
deep like they just know bishop b6 and
then
at some point we'll stray away from
opening preparation
other nice thing about this line for
white it's up to black to prove the
conversation
like okay i'm
i'm a little bit awkward with the king
and development
but i am up two
pieces so
i have to look on the bright side of
life
but now it's time to think because i
don't know what's going on here
i want to play this move
but after takes takes rook b8 and then
somehow the knight gets defended
uh i might play queen d5
windy 5 actually looks natural
there's knight d2 as well
to go for 94 and initiate some trades
i was just imagining funny line
oh it's not so funny though
or is it
here here here here and then takes
maybe this is funny
i think i'll play knight t2
also has the benefit of maybe this move
as well
[Music]
because there's multiple like key
squares to access
yeah normally you play the ponziani for
like a simple
[Music]
central build-up
and not like a crazy
sharp tactical fight where your king is
really misplaced on e2 but
that's what happens
this is when the the ponziani turns into
the bong cloud
question why not bishop g5 yeah this
like
this was a brief consideration i don't
think i even mentioned that move
um i thought it would have left be too
tender and my bishop would be
eventually misplaced
even though it would come with some
initiative
okay now i'm realizing if i play knight
takes e4
black can just take and then takes and
then i get pinned
and that's not so funny
kind of want to play this move
[Music]
excited and looking forward to your otb
tournament next year good luck i'm
excited too
yeah next year but also next month
and what to do here
it feels so uncomfortable being up two
pieces
i could consider taking give a piece
back play bishop e3
try and simplify and then hold on for
dear life
i mean what's the biggest worry takes
takes takes
oh and then knight b3 takes whoa it's
inform hunter
thanks for gifting subs
i think this is actually okay
it's important in these situations not
to be afraid of ghosts
even though it looks scary it might
like the threats just might not exist
now i'm playing knight d4 i call off the
bishop i opened up the queen
so the knight is still defended
yeah i think you inform hunter
gifting ten
okay now that that's defended by the
pawn if i take the pawn
[Music]
this move probably would hurt me
but this move comes to mind
and surprisingly
i feel kind of cozy
it's like a nice wooden cabin
in the midst of a
blizzard i have shelter
i have a nice like bonfire going
i want to roast some s'mores
or some marshmallows and then turn them
into s'mores
up vote for naming this line the
bonziyani
bangziani a
yeah we have to brainstorm future
youtube video titles
okay now i want to take the pawn but
then i
i really get snowed on my fire would be
extinguished
hey eric keep up the good work much love
smile oh thank you
[Music]
smile back
thank you gary too
[Music]
gifting five
so much hype
uh okay there's increment here but i
still have to watch my time
um
i don't think i can take the pawn
i'm actually thinking h3
h3 it looks really slow
but the point i just want to take and
then i have a threat of taking
there's even some idea in the event of
one example on his bishop
does this move
ah so this is another example line so
bishop takes e3 queen d3 king takes f2
and then the king can actually run
to g3 and then h2
and i think that's okay
again it looks scary
my shelter is being invaded
by polar bears but
i think i'm equipped
i'm gonna find a new shelter
like a hermit crab
[Music]
and so many metaphors
the thing here is uh
i just fill up two pieces
the basic strategy was to win material
don't get mated
also don't flag which
could still be a challenge
and then to
someday win in the end game okay
so let's uh enjoy the new shelter
there's a comment rook hanging i think
all the rooks were defended
[Music]
except this rook but it's not attacked
realizing there might be knight f5 not
immediately because this but then this
ah but then some
yeah this rook is potentially in danger
i just want my king on each one
wow g4
i'm not going to get my wish
that's actually kind of a cool move
by playing that f5
i have very little time to think you're
too
uh
i don't know what to do
let's just play queen d5
i'm going to give back a piece
but now i'm more interested in
initiative okay so this is check
and now bishop c4
is running made in one
okay so now the queen okay there's queen
f4 chuck
so i was threatening the queen and mates
but black defended everything
however i'm still up a piece
still not flagging
i don't mind like simplifying further
and then just live on the increments
here we go
okay
good game bolty
i mean really tested me
in this kind of chaotic middle game uh
i'm sure the engine will have something
to say
i wouldn't be surprised if black was
like
much better at some point
but
yeah it's difficult to play for both
players
uh yeah there were a lot of i was
rewarding the patient subs but a lot of
people forgot they were challenging me
okay real quick let's uh
let's see what the engine has to say
because
um
it's a very
very difficult variation to assess
without the use of an engine
which is what kind of makes it fun so
the engine gives like close to a quality
in this line
this should be six maybe even slightly
better for black
and
i remember
so the one game i remember from this
line is shabalov playing white
against hansel target i'm pretty sure
shabal have also played rook g1
it could be way off but
let's look at master's database
yeah shabal of target i think is kind of
a model game to follow
from the white perspective knight f2
[Music]
rook g1
so there's also cb7 here
um
engine says yeah i mean these are the
two candidate moves
so rook g1
ah this game was
bc6 and it
yeah
black didn't sack the second piece
so i'm curious
i wonder if boltzy was prepared for rook
jiwana
yeah castling it's the type of move that
you play if you're
somewhat prepared
i was played very quickly too
you know six was played quickly
so it looks like here this is where
things can kind of branch
there was a question about bishop g5
yeah intuitively it just doesn't look
right
because the queen can just sidestep
arguably
after queen e6 the queen's improved
itself
because now there's queen c4 potential
and the bishops has placed and this pawn
then defended
so
i would think black's doing well well
maybe it's still playable maybe queen g6
is better
queen g6 fighting queen c2 or queen d3
so
[Music]
yeah it's interesting like engine will
sail
decent number of moves are playable here
so i played one of the playable moves
but the dangerous thing about this line
it says black
has full compensation
when the engine gives
close to equal or slightly better for
black
and black is down two minor pieces you
know it's it's dangerous
so i play knight d2
e4
so let's see where things went a
straight for black
knight d4 losing move wow
only move knight c4 it's such a hard
move to play allowing this an e5 opening
[Music]
but it's played once wow
so why is knight d4 losing
only winning move bishop takes d4
i i was gonna take back
knight g4 only winning move
retreating
[Music]
black is still down two pieces
but the threat of
i guess it's a maiden tooth right queen
f2 king d193
if i take the pawn of hitting the queen
defending
queens a d4 only winning move
this is like an insane engine line
king
okay queen d4 hitting the rook and
knight's defended but
yeah white's position is very
loosey-goosey
and now there's lots of ways to win
rook e8 and h2
f5 man
any leeches games
wow so even people on leeches know the
right move
this might be some theory knight c4
if takes
ah queen takes f3 i didn't see this move
rook e8
so apparently white's still okay here
okay i don't want to go down the engine
rabbit hole too much but
a lot of room for analysis
it's a fun variation very topical
ponziani mine
i've sometimes played this as black i
think
um
you can look at my stats here
so as white i played this eight times
and when people play okay the really
only good move
um
i've won three and lost three
out of six games
and let's see how many times i play this
as black
only twice as black
and people are too scared to take the
knights
anyway okay if that game goes on youtube
hello to youtube